hey there friends what up I am on
location about to shoot one of my flow
videos and seemed like an interesting
opportunity to answer a question that
comes up really really really frequently
online uh mostly on my videos which is
those flow videos that I do that show
off the really cool Trails is there any
way to do them with just your cell phone
and as it turns out the answer is yes I
discovered a way to do it and I'm going
to walk you through how in this video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to show you how to
get amazing trails with just your cell
phone but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys pyrot
Tera light to and Ultra poy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-b business
friend of the channel Becca beckon thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission all right so this is
a thing that I get comments on all the
time how do I get those amazing Trails
on my flow videos I did a video a couple
years ago that showed off the exact
technique that I use with my mirrorless
Sony camera and some amazing software
including uh Final Cut Pro but always
always always there is somebody who
comes back in and asks then uh whether
or not it is possible to get similar
video with their cell phone and up until
now I have thought that the answer was
no but I have discovered a way so this
is going to be kind of a Choose Your Own
Adventure because there is a technique
for doing it that requires absolutely
nothing other than a cell phone and
there's a technique for doing it that
involves shooting the video on your cell
phone and then editing it on a laptop
now either way the first step of this
process is you're going to need to
download an app for your phone called
Blackmagic camera that app is going to
essentially expose all the different
pieces that you're going to need in
order to be able to make your camera
record video in a way that's going to
make those Trails visible and if you
intend to keep on editing on your camera
then you're also going to need another
piece of software called luminancer uh
but uh if you are amable to doing your
editing and post- production work on a
laptop you're going to want something
like either Adobe Premiere or Final Cut
Pro I'm going to show you how to do it
in Final Cut Pro because that's what I
use so the first step of this is
actually just setting up the video shoot
properly and that involves if you're
going to shoot with natural lighting as
I am today uh you want to shoot at
Sunset and you specifically want to wait
until the ambient light is dimmer than
the light coming off of the PO depending
upon what set of poy you're using uh
that might mean that you're in for a
weight late in Sunset or it might mean
that you can take your video early in
Sunset but I am definitely right about
at that period of sunset where I should
be setting up because the window of time
you're going to get is very very narrow
so I'm going to go ahead and set up my
phone okay so once you have Blackmagic
camera open the first thing you're going
to do is you're going to go ahead and
change the frame rate you're going to
want to set the frame rate to 60 frames
a second and then you're going to want
to adjust the shutter speed to 1 over 60
yes the word the number 60 does appear
both in frames per second as well as
shutter speed and that is important next
you're going to want to go ahead over
and adjust your ISO you want to set your
ISO to be as low as possible I usually
set it to be just 100 which is usually
the lowest setting
you're going to have to wait until a
point where at 100 ISO and a shredder
speed of 1 over 60 you see the ambient
light kind of uh go down to the point
where you're getting a recognizable
picture if not a somewhat dark picture
we're going to go ahead and wait here
until that happens all right so I'm set
up I have my phone set up as well as my
nice Sony camera because I wanted to
have a backup today just in case and now
I'm waiting for the ambient light to to
get low enough that the POI are brighter
than the light around me which is
probably another 5 or 10 minutes away
and it's waiting for that window that's
always the hardest part um it should be
noted that I could actually shoot right
now just with the Sony because uh the
Sony gives me control over uh aperture
settings so I can artificially induce a
uh a darker picture if I want to but I
don't have that option with uh the cell
phone unfortunately because the aperture
is literally part of the hardware you
cannot change it so I'm just going to
have to wait until things dimm down
enough that uh the sensor will register
the uh po the way I want it to ideally
what I'm looking for is for the picture
to be just a little bit
underexposed the reason being that it'll
make it a lot easier to pull out the
light from the poy when the time comes
for it uh so this is a fun surprise this
is V yes hello hi uh V is a fan just
randomly spotted me as I was setting up
to shoot this video so hi v We
Appreciate You hi everyone he's awesome
go support thank you yeah of course all
right I think it's that time I'm going
to try a first take uh probably we'll
get one maybe two takes before the uh
guards around the capital building here
start messing with me so um yeah keep
your fingers crossed that I get it on
the first one here cuz uh the lighting
conditions look perfect
better girl I guess I'm getting cold let
me
come you'll be Santa
CL so I actually managed to get in a
bunch of takes but annoyingly enough
they did not turn the Christmas tree
itself on until it was already basically
completely dark so I did one last take
that I'm pretty sure is going to be too
dark overall but we'll see how it turns
out but as for right now our work on
location is done to the editing room hey
friends so we are back in the editing
room here and I'm going to show you how
you can go ahead and add those trails to
your video with just applications that
you can find on your phone so let's go
ahead and bring up my screen right quick
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and Export uh
the final video that I recorded that
night it's this one right here and I'm
going to go ahead and uh hit this little
button in at at the top that has the
little screen on it with the Arrow
coming out of it that means that we are
going to save it so I'm going to go
ahead and save video right quick that
means it's now in my camera roll on my
phone so next thing we need to do is we
need to pull this up in an app called
luminancer now you can find luminancer
in the uh IOS as well as Android store I
believe so we go ahead and pull that up
and instantly you're going to see if few
uh different controls here by default it
is set up to kind of capture stuff off
of your live camera we don't want to use
the live camera though um I want you to
click on that icon in the lower right
hand corner that looks like a mountain
with a sun behind it that is going to
pull up stuff in your uh photo roll so
I'm going to go ahead and select that
video that I just saved and I'm going to
hit the button choose if you want to
double check you can always hit the
playy button to make sure it's it's the
video you want I already know this is
the right video so I'm going to hit
choose it's going to take a few minutes
for it to compress and bring it into the
program not the least of which because I
originally recorded this in 4k so it's
going to take a little bit of time let's
just fast forward to that shall we all
right cool so now we have our video
inside of luminancer and the first thing
you'll probably notice is that the
colors look slightly different and that
is because it is already kind of uh
doing its thing where it's trying to
bring out out uh stuff that is light and
add trails to it um few things I want to
go over right quick number one uh the
controls in the upper leftand corner we
have Channel we want to keep that on
light because that is specifically what
it is targeting here color is bright
that is also what we want um we're going
to deal with blend in just a second here
but for right now what I'm going to go
ahead and do is I'm going to go ahead
and play the video uh so I can see kind
of where we're at with what is being
selected and what isn't for these Trails
Now by default um the video is muted
when you're editing in
luminancer um so you might want to make
sure that uh you're doing everything you
can to try and make sure that there's a
very definite cue for when your song is
beginning or what have you when uh uh
when when when you edit the video but
for right now I just want to see where
we're at and as you can
see I'm getting or at least I will be
getting in just a second here
I'm getting decent Trails off of the POI
the problem is that um the appearance of
the capital building is really burnt out
behind me so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to play around with the threshold
slider here just a little bit and I'm
going to move it to the point where that
burnt out look on the capital building
is either completely gone or it's minor
enough that it is not annoying me and as
you can see I've slid the slider far
enough over now
that uh the capital building is no
longer uh being quite so loud in terms
of its brightness and I still got some
good trails going on there so uh if I
want to I can also adjust the slider on
the trails and get slightly different
effects out of it I think where I'm at
is just fine here so now it's time to
talk about the blend function so when we
play around with this we want to select
either invert or mix either one and
you'll notice that when I did that all
of a sudden uh we're we're getting a lot
more color and detail back in the
background and that is because the
program was really just showing us what
it was selecting to add trails to but
now we have both the trails as well as
the quality of the original
footage now there is a catch with
luminancer and that's that I can't just
straight up export this file as it is um
essentially what winds up happening is
the program does a screen recording of
sorts so what I'll wind up doing is
hitting that little recorder button at
the bottom and it'll give me a little
time stamp there to tell me uh how much
time it has spent recording the video
and uh unfortunately if you have a
longer video you're probably going to
wait want to wait for the thing to loop
around and start back up again but I
don't have the patience to do it this
time around um so I'm just going to
capture about 20 30 seconds of footage
here zering in on it and when I get to
that magical 30 second point I'm going
to hit the stop button and now this is
the video that luminancer has prepared
for me where we have our nice background
we have our nice Trails looks lovely uh
it gives me two options here one to
share one to save I'm going to go ahead
and save it with that green button with
the arrow pointing down cool so now that
video is in my camera roll and now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go ahead
and pull up that video in particular
here cuz there's there's one more step
that I want to do here and that's that I
want to adjust some of the settings here
um to try and brighten it up a wee bit
so I will go to
adjustments and as I'm playing it here
uh first and foremost I'm going to go
over to exposure and I'm just going to
increase the exposure a bit to make sure
that everything's a little bit more
visible in it
and I would say that that is definitely
an
improvement there's more detail in the
background I can see myself a little bit
more but I think that there's still a
little bit more room for uh for
improvement here so I'm also going to go
over to brightness and I'm going to
increase the overall brightness of it
just a here and once again if we check
out the difference between the two I
think that that is an improvement so at
this point I think that this is a good
version of this file and we can go ahead
and hit done save the video and this is
something that you can now post on
social media if you want to and doesn't
it look cool get those very very clear
trails and we get plenty of detail
around me as well as uh the background
uh yeah there's a lot to like here that
said um I think that there are some
other options that we can Embrace here
that involve uh a more heavy heavy duty
editing program on my computer so I'm
going to switch us over to that right
now all right so the method I just
showed you for editing your Trails
videos on your phone will work uh very
clearly uh the results of it come out
looking just fine but for me personally
there are specific things that I want to
have more control over with the trails
that unfortunately I just can't get with
Lumin answer um so I do want to show you
a more uh comprehensive way to get those
trails but it also involves using a PC
or laptop instead of just simply using
your phone so if your phone is all that
you have don't need to watch any further
of this video but if you'd like to get
slightly better versions of those Trails
or much better versions of those Trails
depending let me guide you through how I
do that um so first and foremost we need
to get that footage off the phone you
know I already covered how you can uh
save the footage to your uh
uh to your photo library from there if
you're using an Apple product you can
just uh use airdrop to get it to your uh
your uh laptop or uh desktop what
whatever your uh item of choice is there
and uh I'm going to be using Final Cut
Pro for this because it's just the
editing program that I uh tend to prefer
for doing this stuff uh but you can just
as easily do this I think inside both uh
Premiere Pro as as well as D Vinci
resolve but here's how I do it in Final
Cut Pro so first and foremost uh we've
gone ahead and we've copied our file
over here um I'm going to go over to
Final Cut and I'm going to create us a
new library and I'm just going to call
this Library Trails
demo and in here we're going to go ahead
and create a new event which is also
going to be called Trails
demo now here's our footage I'm going to
copy that over into my new library here
and the editing process is going to be a
multi-step process so the first thing I
need to do I'm going to rightclick on
this video and I'm going to hit new
project that will mean that I automatic
the the project automatically inherits
um the resolution of the video as well
as the frame rate we do want to hang on
to both of those things um we're going
to go ahead and call this Trails demo uh
stage one there's a reason I'm calling
it stage
one I'm going to hit okay and that
automatically populates uh a new project
with this video here so we're going to
need to make two copies of this I'm
going to click on it I'm going to copy
it and then I'm going to come over here
to the uh end of this video's placement
on the timeline and I'm going to paste
another copy of it so now we've got two
copies of it sitting here in the
timeline and of course this little uh
buffer zone of of blackp space here
because with the magnetic timeline that
we get in Final Cut it's not like you
can just have two clips that are sitting
apart from each other and uh that that
just that just goes so the first thing I
need to do is come down here to uh over
here in video we have our list of
effects and there's a specific effect I
need to pull up it's under masks and
keying and it is the effect called Luma
I need to pull that over and what you're
going to see then is a bunch of the
video is going to go dark the reason
being everything that you see go dark
now is now transparent in this copy of
the video uh over here I'm going to
adjust the Luma so I'm going to go ahead
and slide it up until the sky disappears
and it's probably also going to be a
good idea for me to get rid of as much
of the building as possible cuz
otherwise whenever my body passes in
front of it uh portions of my body will
disappear and I may come to regret this
but I'm going to go head and bring the
slider up just a little bit more until I
get rid of uh a bunch of the capital
Dome as well I'm not going to get rid of
all of it because I have a suspicion
that the brightness of the red PO is
going to turn out to be pretty close to
the brightness of the Dome uh and I
don't want to lose that entirely so uh
back over here I'm going to look at
video all and I'm going to scroll really
close to the bottom here where there is
an effect effect that I want to get
called Trails going to drag that over
and now you can see short Trails already
starting up here just barely and what
I'm going to do is go over here to
Echoes and I'm going to max out the
Echoes and now you can see that there's
this seamless kind of blur here and I'm
going to go ahead and adjust things a
little bit I think I'm going to increase
the uh duration to 0.25 which will give
me some slightly longer Trails here cool
so let let's go ahead and pull that over
and uh I took the second clip and I
basically placed it on top of the first
clip now what that means is that all of
the things that I can see in this clip
that is uh the stuff that's lit up and
the trails associated with it is going
to be layered on top of and remember all
the black areas here are actually
transparent it's going to be layered on
top of the normal footage so look at
that I now
have that bottom footage still showing
the picture that I intended and on top
of it I have my Trails now you'll note
something just went kind of screwy here
and that's because um I got past the one
minute mark on this and uh actually I
should uh because there's a thing I
should do real quick which is cut this
close to the beginning of the of the
music so let me do that right
quick and I'm going to need to turn off
the top layer because the computer's
going to be doing too much work trying
to fill in those Trails so let's save it
to work right now so it can track in
real
time cool that'll do I'm going to go
ahead and cut those beginning Parts out
so I don't have to render them more than
I need to and um the top layer here that
shows the trails I'm going to go ahead
and uh bring it back to 100% opacity and
I'm going to look for a specific frame
here that happens right around the one
minute Mark it's right here and what
this is is nobody's been able to explain
this to me but there's a glitch that
happens in this plugin for Final Cut
where for some reason at uh roughly a
minute um it like starts over it Loops
the trails from the very beginning of
the clip so just what that means is I'll
go to a minute and cut the clip into two
so it starts over again and it looks
just perfectly normal and then I will
jump to the next
minute and
it's interesting do you see how in the
background here I have the trails from
the beginning of this clip have started
up again and they're no longer linked to
where the PO actually are in this clip
yeah it's very annoying so there's the
point where we have the break I'm going
to go ahead and insert a cut there so
now we should be in a situation where um
we have the trails in the proper
placement with our uh with our hand
hands here um and I am noticing there's
a like here let me let me see if I can
find a spot where this happens but uh do
you see how you can see the lights in
the capital building through me um
there's no real way to get rid of that
unfortunately um because the lights are
as bright as the POI um but like
hopefully the uh the trails from the POI
will be uh will be uh cool enough that
people won't be concentrating that much
on it and and I'm going to move back and
forth here to see if there are any
points where I'm really moving in front
of that Dome and I need to worry about
part of me getting cut off it looks like
that is not the case great cool that's
what I was hoping for okay so next thing
we go on up here to um this little tab
for titles and generators so I'm going
to pull this up and now in Final Cut I'm
seeing uh our title and Generator
selections here and under titles I have
um a
custom uh plugin here installed uh
called adjustment layer and I'm going to
go ahead and drag that adjustment layer
down
between the layers here so it's going to
be on top of the base layer which is
just me spinning and underneath the
layer that is just the lights and the
trails and I'll show you why I'm doing
this here it is because um I can go
ahead and make color adjustments to the
bottom layer with without making any
impact on the top layer so what I
generally will do here is I'll start off
in color curves and I'll pick somewhere
like in the mid to low mid range uh for
the Luma and I'll go ahead and bump it
up and I will bump it up to a point
where uh I'm kind of adjusting for the
darkness in the frame and I start to get
a uh a a little bit more detail coming
in um
you know I'm back lit here so there's
only so much detail I'm going to get
from my own body but this gives me back
some parts of the sky um it definitely
illuminates the capital building a
little bit more than I would like so I
think I'm going to I'm I'm going to be a
little uh a little bit more conservative
with this than I usually am um and then
of course if you want to fine-tune
anything you can open up a color board
and say you know oh I want to brighten
up the high parts or I just want to
brighten up the mids or something like
that I don't think either one of those
really add all that much here maybe
maybe the highs do a little bit of work
here yeah I I'll I'll hold on to that
and then I'm going to bring down the
adjustment layer and put another one on
top of all of the clips and the reason
is that I'm going to go ahead and uh do
a color board here going to saturation
I'm going to bump up the saturation in
this and now all of a sudden all all
those colors are going to pop in a way
that they didn't in the original footage
so layer by layer we can see what's
happening here because um what I can do
here is I can go ahead
oops it it adjusts everything okay that
that's fine so what I can do is I can
stick my adjustment layers uh over here
to keep them out of the way for a second
and you can see what the footage
originally looked like it's super dark
there's not a lot of detail here and
when I bring back in the first
adjustment layer yay all of a sudden you
can see more stuff and when I bring back
in the second adjustment layer hey all
those colors are popping now great all
right so my next stage of this is that
I'm going to export this file I'm going
to go ahead and hit share export file uh
Trails demo stage one um I did shoot
this at 4K so I'm going to export this
at 4K go ahead and hit
next and I will create a new folder for
this Trails
demo hit
create and I'll go ahead and Export it I
don't know how long it's going to take
it's probably going to take a little
while so we can go ahead and fast
forward to the point where uh I'm done
exporting it and uh we can move on to
the next
step okay well as predicted uh that took
forever to render but we are back so um
yeah I'm going to go dig us up the fully
rendered version of it right here and
I'm going to bring it right back into
Final Cut and here's why um so I'm now
going to create a new project and unlike
our last project which was at 4K and 60
uh frames per second I'm instead going
to set it at uh 23.98 I could just set
it at 24 but um I'm used to
using things like 23.98 and
29.97 because that's what my uh Sony
camera shoots at so it's kind of just
force a habit at this point but we'll
call this Trails
[Music]
demo
and I am now going to drop this rendered
video in which is great because now I
can actually watch it in real time I'm
going to turn the volume down so I don't
get a copyright notice on this but
essentially I can see now how the video
actually turned out and one thing that I
can definitely see in this is that
um it may not have been the smartest
move on my part to have one of the POI
lit up red because um as you can see
here the the uh green light is showing
up way better on camera than the red one
um but it'll work for our purposes so
what do I do with it at this point well
you can definitely see the difference uh
between it uh played back at 24 frames a
second which I prefer because um it
makes it more cinematic uh versus uh the
original version which is uh at a full
60 frames a
second so what's happened then basically
is because I shot it at 60 frames a
second and a shutter speed of 1 over 60
and now I've um imported all this into a
project that is 24 frames a second uh
basically what that means is that I
simulated a effect that is common with
film called the 180° shutter rule that
um makes it so that uh you're able to
get some crispness in the picture but
also a little bit of motion blur um
which otherwise would not be possible
because you have to have the shutter
speed equal to the frame rate if you're
going to do Trails like this so um what
I can do now is um if I want to I can do
some additional fine tuning on uh the
exposure and the like I think it's
pretty close to what I want there though
um and one thing I can do is um I can go
ahead and add a little bit of a vignette
to it so I can you know add a shape
mask like
so and then
say on the outside that I want to drop
uh exposure by like -10 and that just
creates this little vignette around it
so it focuses attention in the center of
the video um so now it's ready for me to
say if I wanted to uh go ahead and grab
a copy of the audio file and uh drop it
in to get better audio quality or I can
just upload it as is but as you can see
uh came out pretty good uh I would
definitely say that um there's a little
bit more visible here than there is with
the version that I made in uh luminancer
but you know luminancer is also a
totally acceptable way to go about doing
this so there you have it then friends
you've got two different options for
adding trails to uh videos that you take
with your cell phone and a complete walk
through as to how you can add those
Trails either with a laptop uh or
desktop or uh with your phone depending
upon which option you prefer uh so go
forth and make some pretty videos uh I'd
love to see
them um so yeah if you got anything out
of this video please uh make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to keep
the conversation going and of course to
help my channel grow
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you you all rock
and uh if you like the videos that I
produce and you like to see me make more
of them uh you can make that happen uh
by sending up to support them over on
patreon you can do that at patreon.com
drexfactor poy where you can find a
whole bunch of Awesome awards that you
can sign up for uh but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if you
want to check out the last Deep dive I
did into how to create these Trails um
which include things like camera
settings if you're using a mirrorless or
DSLR camera uh as well as a walkthr on
how you do make the same technique work
in uh Adobe Premiere I will go ahead and
include a link to that up on screen as
well as down in the description thank
you so much for watching I hope this
answers some questions for those of you
all out there and uh I hope you're
having a good new year friends the
performance video I Shot here should be
live now so let me know how I did take
care now and have a good one peace